the southern Port City of Harrison is
not the first place to emerge from
occupation earlier in the war Ukrainian
troops marched into the town of butcher
occupied for weeks by Russian forces and
this is what they found
human rights investigators from the
Nobel prize-winning Center for civil
liberties say alleged war crimes
committed against civilians in butcher
are likely to point to much larger scale
atrocities in Herson where Russian
forces have been for more than eight
months I'm really scared about what we
will find in Hearthstone
when people ask why butchered so many
people was killed more than 500 because
that in that moment that would be a city
which were released and see what
happened there
so we expect a lot a lot of
killed people a lot of people who was
attacked in herself in her Zone exactly
recently discovered CCTV footage from
butcher captured across the street from
a Russian interrogation Center at 144
yabloonska Street reveals some of the
methods of occupation in this case nine
men are LED at gunpoint towards the
building
in the basement below civilians
sometimes hooded and bound were held for
days on end
local council member dimitro hapuchenko
managed to escape after a night in
captivity
uh they asked me where I work and I knew
if I told them I'm a counselor my fate
would be sealed
in the backyard above on the 5th of
March eight of the nine men seen earlier
were executed a crime witnessed by
neighbors this building carries the
obvious scars of the horrors that took
place here but it also Bears Clues as to
the operating methods of occupying
Russian forces
Clues pointing to perhaps even greater
Horrors yet to be discovered elsewhere
for the thousands who've remained inside
her son enduring the occupation for many
months the joy of liberation of seeing
Ukraine's flag fly again of tearing down
signs proclaiming Russia's annexation of
their region will soon give way to an
investigation into possible crimes of
War committed there one man who won't be
around to testify is kiril stramusov
Ukrainian collaborator Russian installed
Deputy Mayor a man who would have known
much about what went on killed this week
in an alleged car accident and buried
with honors in occupied Crimea just as
Russia completed its withdrawal Jonah
Hall Al Jazeera in butcher